hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot's
III stage we are here with another
developer interview I'm your host Mike
McCarty here with Rob handler Hey
and Andrew Golota from EA I guess we are
here to talk about battlefield one it's
got a lot of DLC on the horizon yeah
tell us what we were seeing yesterday
the other day at a conference yeah so we
had a few big announcements we're
revolutionizing the game in some big
ways the first thing is we've of course
have our monthly updates that we just
started in May and we're bringing out
Novell Knights that's coming out later
this month it's the first night map to
Battlefield one and then later in July
we're also bringing out priests a her I
almost ruined that French community so
that's the second night map that we're
bringing out and those both are
extensions of they shall not pass so
that's that's the first big thing so
some night maps they're gonna be trench
warfare both of these things are what
our community has been asking for the
second big change of course is in the in
the name of the Czar I mean that's huge
huge thing this is the most extensive
expansion pack we've ever brought so
we're doing six maps as more weapons
more vehicles more gameplay changes
we're doing some big big things and that
brings me to the third big stuff change
for this is is the game play so we're
focusing on progression and we're also
focusing on on operations so we want to
really update both of those who make
them richer and deeper experiences I do
want to get into in the name of the
Czar's but first with night maps how
does that affect the actual like
moment-to-moment gameplay from
battlefield one yeah I think with the
night maps you're gonna have to change
some of your tactics you can't just go
guns blazing all the time because you're
gonna have a little bit of a limited
visibility we tried to do a really good
job at balancing and we were very
sensitive about how we balanced out the
lighting on the map making sure that you
can still see around you still see some
of your enemies and still be competitive
in this environment but there still are
gonna be some very dark corners and
nooks and crannies that you can hide in
and and this changes the way that you
play I mean someone could be around the
corner you don't know so you have to
listen in to your audio make sure that
you're you're if you're listening to
footsteps behind you or around you
and there's some really cool things that
are in this map for Nivelle nights we
have this is the big trench map and it's
actually a symmetrical map so the
trenches are kind of they're the same
layout on both sides so the way that we
have made it where you can kind of
locate where you are in the map is with
the lighting on one side the German side
you have electric lights you have
spotlights and lightbulbs lighting up
and that was true to history the the
Germans they they fortified their
trenches and they were there for the
long haul the French you see they have
they have fire and lanterns and they
have these with it's more organic style
and they were there thinking that it was
gonna be a quick quick battle so they
didn't spend a lot of time fortifying
fortifying their their their trench so
for this that's a great little tip to
know where you are in the map which
direction are you facing and then in
between is a no-man's land filled with
tons of cover as you try to attack and
defend both sides that seems a very much
time - I would imagine like an
Operations type mode for this is that
correct
so we we won't have operations on this
map do you have front lines which is the
the new game-mode that was introduced
with nahshon out pass so that's green
brought to to the map as well cool oh
yeah that mean like you were just
mentioning the difference between the
French and the German trenches I assume
there's just as much effort to have like
blend some historical accuracy to the
DLC just was the case with the main game
right yes of course yeah I mean one of
our big pillars is of course to be
authentic and so we do a ton of studies
and research and we work with historians
to make sure that we're we're being
authentic and true and we are still
making a game so it's got to be fun and
and so that's that's a big part of it
and and for Battlefield one the big part
for us is to tell the untold stories
what are the things that you might not
have known about World War one and we're
thrilled that our players are getting
really into it and excited about all the
details that are going into this yeah I
imagine a ton of research went into the
Russian front right because in the name
of the Czar brings in a whole new army a
new front Maps yeah based in like a mono
II Tundra kind of that's right yeah can
you tell us like what to expect and the
names are yeah yeah so in the name of
the Czar is moved
our battles we were in the Western Front
for most of the game so we're moving
everyone over to the Eastern Front the
biggest front of World War one and we're
introducing the Russian army with that
comes for for vehicles we're gonna be
bringing an armored truck and a the
biggest bomber and battlefield one
called the Ilya Muromets it has four
engines it looks lights here this
thing's giant and it packs a punch with
all the all the bombs
we also are bringing in a Y lighter
landing craft and this is a little boat
to transport troops and also we're
updating the cavalry unit we're bringing
a new cavalry unit we've enhanced it to
introduce the hussar and these guys
carry around the lance and they run
around very quick quick attacks and you
can impale your enemies and drag them
off the battlefield it's nuts that was
definitely in the trailer yeah memorable
moment were there any kind of like major
things with the base game that you
wanted to maybe change or supplement
with in the name of the Czar that really
worked well in terms like like
overarching systems or how the game just
function as a whole is there anything
you really wanted to address so of
course we're always looking at ways to
enhance the game make it better or
tweaking balance making sure if you
listening to our community about what
they want and and where they feel like
there might be some balance and issues
but for in the name of azar we are
updating to big core areas progression
this is something our players really are
passionate about and we're doing it in
two big ways the first one is we are
we're introducing all new assignments
and this is gonna help the players that
have things to go after that are gonna
help kind of advance their career and as
you do so we're gonna also be bringing
in what we're calling specializations
and these specializations are gonna help
you tailor your class to your play style
and so it's something you haven't seen
in battlefield yet and we're super
excited to bring that can you go in more
and especially I don't know
unfortunately I can't yeah I will have a
lot more to share in the coming months
okay but in terms of the six new maps
and like just I you know you have the
new behemoth which was the Train with
the snow plow on the front yes on the
trailer when EA announced it at the
press conference you also have just like
a different new whole new army like
presumably new weapons and everything
yes how do you even begin to tackle
something this big with like an
expansion of the game you know it takes
a lot of work and it's a team effort
for us to really be able to execute on
this so our historian they help us and
we have some people on the team there
are experts of weapons experts of
vehicles and and so we do a deep dive
study on everything around around this
this particular part of the war around
Russia around their involvement and then
we start laying out what can we what can
we bring to the game one of the great
things also we ended up coming across
was the women's battalion of death this
is a little an untold story that I I
didn't know about until we started
really diving yet and these women were
both capable and courageous they would
charge the frontlines often when the
rest of the army wouldn't come and
support them
and they would take ground so we had to
have them in the game so we brought them
in the game as the support excuse me the
Scout class in in the Russian army yeah
we've seen the Russian front of like
World War two in several like Call of
Duty shoes probably the first time we're
seeing the Russian front of World War
one in a game yes like kind of setting
the precedent you know it's it's it's
interesting as we look at the world and
and what the landscape was at that time
you have to look at you know 1914 to
1918 and what what were the landscapes
and and we had to pull a lot of
reference materials out and there's
actually quite a few photos around that
time and it's a lot of history a lot of
written material and and so we really
had to take some time to test study
about what's what what does this world
look like so when we go to Luke Cal pass
the map that were showing a TA play we
have the this is on mountainous ravines
and this is a really interesting
location to call it it's the Carpathian
Mountains and this would there was a
there was a crossing in there that was a
trading route and it was really critical
to the war what when if you controlled
that trading route you can control how
you supply your troops so it was really
important to Astro Hungarians had had to
hold and the the Russians were trying to
take it and that's the beginning of one
of our operations that we're bringing
called Brusilov offensive yeah every
time you're looking back at like
historical battles or wars that extended
into Russia like one of the main enemies
for the invaders is the winter yeah I
imagine whether most playing into like
especially with the dynamic weather
the one is kind of bound to be known for
imagine we'll be seeing blizzards or
something you absolutely will so we have
we have the daylight of course there
goes into snow we're gonna have
blizzards but unlike what you you might
have seen in some other maps where
sometimes like storms would come and it
might stay for a long time the the
blizzards are gonna come and go and
we'll see if they you know they but they
will hinder your your visibility they
are gonna affect you and how you your
strategy of how you're gonna play the
map and you can check it out right now
at EA play up through the end of today
and and we'll have a lot more to share
with that in the coming months
that's actually pretty interesting how
you mentioned the weather being shorter
opposed to longer because I know that
like some of the desert maps the longer
the storm you can make that preparation
okay I'm gonna shift to a you know a
shotgun yeah and stick with it but it
sounds like you like could you speak on
maybe ask how long are these these
changes and weather cuz it just seems to
be in the case of I'm just gonna play a
little differently for what may be a few
minutes and then go back into like yeah
I mean you mean as far as changing your
loadout you know that's that's a tough
one because whether it's dynamic it's
gonna happen on the on the fly and it's
not something that we've programmed to
necessarily like oh fifteen minutes of
this and then it's going so it's gonna
just kind of occur and but we were but
we're programming that it to be
something that comes and goes and ebbs
and flows through the match but ya know
so yeah you will have to change some of
your tactics but I think it's gonna be
how you how you handle the map and where
you go in the direction of which points
are you trying to control sure you
mentioned the ville knights the one we
just saw like yeah way of that that's
more of a symmetrical map with the
no-man's land the middle the trench on
each side yeah well you would think of
anything warm or one when you have six
new apps to work with within the name of
the Czar DLC is there a specific kind of
map you're going for or like this is
having six different ones allow you to
say this could be a symmetrical one this
could be more of like a long-range
oriented one that's what can be more of
like a battle meeting in the center one
of their any kind of new maps that dice
wanted to tackle with the level design
specifically yeah yeah absolutely it's
actually very similar to what you're
saying for the for the second half right
like we are looking at the whole package
right where how far whatever we are
shown in battlefield and what can we
show right we we've already shown maps
that are symmetrical we've already shown
maps that take place in different
regions and so kay what's new what can
we do that's new
so with Luke Cal Pass for example it's a
it's a mountainous ravine so you have a
lot of vertical gameplay a lot of these
these changes in the environment with
whether it's an you're in the ravines
these credit ease these rocky ravines or
whether you're in the tree lines so
those are the things that that we're
looking at and how can we change the
gameplay when we go into each of the
maps so some of the other maps that
we're bringing I can talk about three
more outside of Luke got passed out and
then the other two I'm holding it we
have to hold until later I wish I can
tell you guys more but for these other
three we have galicia it's a valley map
so this is gonna be the one that's gonna
share how wide an expansive the eastern
front really is and it's gonna be one
that you want to use a lot of your
vehicles for then we go into that's the
beginning of the Brusilov operations by
the way you're gonna work your way up
the Carpathian Mountains up to the
Brusilov keep and this is a little town
up in the mountains so you're gonna have
a little more urban gameplay and then
you're gonna go down into the peninsula
Islands and these islands are it's kind
of a lock of islands that you're gonna
be able to go in and out of and and this
is when the German troops we're trying
to advance onto Russian territory and so
the Russians were finding them off using
large coastal battery cannons dang
sounds is that where you're you
mentioned the Russian piteous boat yeah
that's gonna carry troops it seems like
appropriate that's exactly right that's
why we're introducing this boat we know
that sometimes swimming may not be the
fun all right so you have a boat you can
travel in between the islands and make
your way to to the capture points
awesome cool is there anything else you
want to add that we didn't ask you about
before we close out you know I this is
we're thrilled to be bringing everybody
to the Eastern Front and be able to show
more of what we're doing and we're just
for us the big thing is we wanted to
we're bringing the new new changes to
the game that are going to revolutionize
how you play and I'll revolutionize
where you're going and and and we're
bringing it to you in all new ways like
with our monthly updates so yeah I'm
real excited and I hope everyone enjoys
that all the con
cool Andrew Golota thank you so much for
coming on our u3 stage thank you for
having me appreciate it guys
yeahbsolutely had fun anybody watching
from home we will have more coming from
battlefield one in the name of the Czar
we'll have captured gameplay going up
and GameSpot throughout the week and
then news from every other press
conference and a lot of demos up here on
the stage so be sure to stay tuned for
that we'll see you then